The most important thing to keep in mind
about data cleaning, is that it's an iterative process.
We iterate on first detecting, and then correcting bad
records. Let's look at some examples. We might have
text where we expect to find numeric data. So
the word two instead of the number two. Some
data items might not be designed according to our
specification. They might be missing entire fields. They might
have extra fields. Or, for example with JSON documents, fields
might not have the structure we expect at all. We
might have numbers that are out of range. How many
people do you know who are minus three years of age?
The mighty outliers compared to a standard distribution. We might
have an American expatriate in the London office who did
some data entry, and coded in a few dates using
the U.S. format when the system was expecting the European format.